hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the diagnosis matters elevating
the standard of care for women impacted
by vaginitis and vaginosis presented by
dr. charissa Culbreth and Chrissy jewel
of lab or ten I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational life seminars
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by BD BB is a global medical
technology company that is advancing the
world of health by improving medical
discovery diagnostics and the delivery
of care to learn more about our sponsor
please visit molecular diagnostics bt
comm
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation now if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or just let us know
you're having a problem by using the ask
a question box this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I would now like to present to you
today's speaker dr. Karissa Cobras
scientific director of infectious
diseases tricor reference laboratories
and assistant professor of pathology
University of New Mexico Health Sciences
Centre for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Cole Brest
you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone I'm very pleased to be
able to bring you the presentation today
the diagnosis matters elevating the
standard of care for women impacted by
vaginitis and vaginosis
for today's objectives we are going to
describe the complexities and challenges
of diagnosing and vaginitis and
vaginosis and these complexities are
really due to significant symptom
overlap Co inception and Co detection of
multiple organisms and pathogens that
may be associated with vaginitis and
looking at an update of the current
guidelines as they apply to the
challenges related to Diagnostics I will
also be able to describe a few of the
diagnostic testing options that are
currently available along with the
benefits of limitations of each of these
options and then looking at some of the
emerging methodologies for molecular
testing and how this will impact
Diagnostics in the future based on a
study that has been performed in my
laboratory but first a bit about the
vaginal microbiome and and really I add
then a plural there the vaginal
microbiome and because we're starting to
learn much more about the the various
compositions of the vaginal microbiome
but so unique to the vaginal microbiome
we find that a single genus which is
called lactobacillus is predominated in
this microbiome space and this is unique
because in many of the other body
systems that have microbiomes the skin
microbiome the oral mucosa that got mic
mucosa there's usually a broader
composition of organisms that are found
at various levels and in various
individuals in those body sites but what
we find with the vaginal microbiome is
it really across people and across the
population we find that it's
predominated by lactobacillus and this
is likely because lactobacillus produces
lactic acid that has a significant
impact
of reducing the vaginal pH and this
reduction of the vaginal pH is important
for maintaining or normal healthy
vaginal flora but even within the
composition of the vaginal microbiome
with lactobacillus multiple what's been
described as community state types have
been described among the population and
these different community state types
may have different compositions within
them but they are typically dominated by
one or more species of lactobacillus and
so what we find is that although there
seems to be some uniformity with the
vaginal microbiome being predominated by
lactobacillus even within that we do
find some diversity with the different
species of lactobacillus that may be
present or the different organisms that
are also associated within those normal
healthy microbiome in the vaginal tract
what we also find is that the the
microbiome is not just a static the
vaginal microbiome is not a static
entity and so in this study that looked
at the microbiomes
of several women a large population of
women over time what was found is that
the microbiome though typically
dominated by just a few species can have
some fluctuations and changes over time
so that it is not just a static entity
but the organisms represented in the
microbiome can change in these the
factors that would influence the changes
in the vaginal microbiome include things
like sexual activity menstruation that
happen in a continuous manner but then
also episodic factors like pregnancy or
the initiation or completion of
menopause can have
significant changes on the overall
composition of the vaginal microbiome so
it's not just this one static entity but
there's many changes that can occur at
any given period in a vaginal a normal
healthy vaginal microbiome and so when
we take this all together to try to
understand how does the vaginal
microbiome impact human health and
disease
what has been described is that when
there is a higher amount of community
stability so that is that the microbiome
is as normal so you could say as
possible that is heavily predominated by
lactobacillus with some other supporting
organisms that are available then the
the normal vaginal microbiome is healthy
and is able to support a more healthy
state as the diversity of that community
begins to increase in the lactobacillus
loses its predominance in the microbiome
as you can see on the lower part of this
slide this change in the microbiome can
create a space where there may be a more
likelihood that disease states could
occur so these disease states including
vaginitis and vaginosis but not only
that we have seen that as the community
diversity increases and there's that
loss of the lactobacillus dominance in
the microbiome there's increased risk
for transmission of sexually transmitted
infections increased risk of
transmission of HIV and then we also see
the presence of organisms normally
associated with vaginitis and vaginosis
such as trichomonas and other infections
so this vaginal microbiome overall is
sniff acun impact on the vaginal health
in in a patient and so if we go to the
next slide this was a very interesting
study that looked at the vaginal
community and so I'm going to walk you
through this slide because it's a little
bit complicated but it does highlight
some very interesting factors of how
laso bacillus does play this important
role and this important relationship
with other organisms that may be found
in the vaginal space so what you can see
is that there are multiple organisms
that are listed on the lower and on the
right hand side of this graph and what
we see is a relationship of these
organisms to one another and then
multiple states of the vaginal
microbiome and so what this first lets
us know is that lactobacillus
lactobacillus as was described earlier
are usually not found in the presence of
other genera
so when we see lactobacillus as you can
see on the lower side of the slide and
then you can see on the right-hand side
of this slide that lactobacillus general
goes you know only up the first quarter
or so of the organisms listed there the
green means that they're found
associated with one another so that
these lactobacillus are generally found
together and they're not usually found
in the presence of other general what we
also see is if you look just to the left
of the green box and there is a
categorization of the Nugent's core
which is a classification of the normal
microbiome in a way that we can diagnose
bacterial vaginosis and so we see that
these lower Nugent scores which means
that the bad micro flora is more normal
is
associated with lactobacillus and a
predominance of lactobacillus which is
exactly what we would expect but then we
also see that these other organisms so
we see this red box that's over to the
right of the slide these are many other
organisms that are listed here
these other organisms these are usually
not associated with lactobacillus and
they are associated with having the
highest Nugent's score whereas the
lactobacillus species that we see are
usually associated with lower Nugent
score again highlighting the fact that
lactobacillus predominating in the
vaginal microflora
are usually associated with a more
normal and healthy microbiome but
there's a whole variety of other
organisms that are not associated with
lactobacillus but are usually associated
with higher Nugent's scores and ends us
opportunity for more disease that may be
present including vaginitis vaginosis
but then also a higher risk for
acquisition potentially other pathogens
in the vaginal tract and so you know
taking all of this together we see that
diagnosis of a tinnitus and vaginosis is
not just a single pathogen challenge
it's not just a question of is there one
thing that may or may not cause disease
we're also looking at the protective
factor that lactobacillus display as it
relates to the normal healthy vaginal
tract and so we have various methods
that we can use to try to detect the
organisms associated with vaginitis but
they also have significant challenges
that we'll explore further in the next
few slides
I'm so vaginitis itself so the disease
state that will be discussing for the
remainder of the tacos are the most
common gynecologic diagnosis that is
seen in primary care and so if you look
at the relative proportion of
individuals that would experience
disease we see that bacterial vaginosis
is the most common was up to 50% of
women presenting with bacterial
vaginosis and then 20 to 25% prevalence
in the population with vulva vaginal
candidiasis or VVC
a slightly smaller proportion of
patients with a prevalence of
trichomonas and then there's also
non-infectious vaginitis that is vaginal
symptoms that are not necessarily
associated with an infectious pathogen
and that's at a lower percentage at 5%
these all are characterized by a common
symptoms though they may be slightly
more prevalent in one one infection or
the other but the symptoms have
significant overlap and that is patients
presenting with increased or thickened
discharge with odor itching and burning
and then did general vaginal and urinary
tract discomfort so bacterial vaginosis
typically presents with what's described
as a fishy or older a syn and homogenous
discharge and then generalized pelvic
discomfort important to the diagnostic
considerations for bacterial vaginosis
this is not necessarily just a disease
causing the discomfort there significant
other sequelae associated with bacterial
vaginosis which include preterm delivery
and premature rupture of membranes and
pregnant patients experience
experiencing bacterial vaginosis there's
been several many many studies that have
described an increased risk of
the acquisition of sexually transmitted
infections as well as increase the risk
of acquisition of HIV and then also
higher amounts of shedding of the HIV
virus in the vaginal space for patients
who are both HIV positive and positive
for BV there's higher loads of BV our
sorry HIV found in the vaginal
secretions it's also associated with the
development of pelvic inflammatory
disease and so what's important to
recognize that is there is a specific
and unique treatment for bacterial
vaginosis but different for the
treatment for instance of the other
causes of vaginitis and that is
metronidazole that does have a pretty
good cure rate but we do see that there
is a fairly high rate of recurrence that
may do be due to reinfection or relapse
of dis vaginal dysbiosis that can occur
in up to 58 percent of patients and so
BV though it may be considered has just
may be a low-risk burden but not
necessarily you know disease of huge
clinical impact and though it has
significant morbidity may be not such a
high mortality what we do see is there's
a significant global burden of bacterial
vaginosis and you can see the prevalence
across the globe is fairly similar
despite the country or the continent
that's being represented here in this
slide so there's a pretty significant
challenge that we face with the
diagnosis of bacterial vaginosis across
the globe and so for vocal vaginal
candidiasis the presentation has
significant overlap as mentioned with
bacterial vaginosis but there are some
unique characteristics with vocal
vaginal candidiasis the presentation is
more of a white and thick discharge
rather than the thin
homogenous discharge there's no odor
necessarily associated with candidiasis
but the presentation of itching and
burning is presents some important
considerations and diagnostic
considerations to think about for vulva
vaginal candidiasis is that while
Candida albicans is the most common
Candida species associated with a
candidiasis
there are non albicans organisms that
are associated with this disease and the
prevalence can range from five to sixty
percent depending on the population and
the number of recurrences that are
identified and recurrence vulval vaginal
candidiasis this is usually described as
four or more episodes of symptomatic
candidiasis vocal vaginal candidiasis
with within one year and it's been
described at non albicans candida are
can be more significantly associated
with recurrent bvc that can be seen and
so if we look at this next slide it
shows us this nice depiction of lifetime
patterns of vulva vaginal candidiasis
whereas the you know routine over a life
span you can see that you know an
individual may present with multiple
episodes just kind of a routine multiple
episodes of Candida over a lifetime but
then there also can be again associated
with hormonal related candidiasis so in
this slide the lighter pink area is the
reproductive age as you can see that at
time periods of pregnancy or time
periods of menopause or use of hormone
replacement therapies there can be an
increased number of
episodes of vulva vaginal candidiasis
that would occur related to these
hormone changing events in the life of
the patient then on the bottom we see an
example of a patient that experiences
recurrent vulva vaginal candidiasis and
so we see many more episodes that are
much more closely linked and on the
bottom what you can see is that there
are these four episodes that are very
sequential and very tightly clustered
there and in the use of suppressive
therapy is to try to diminish the amount
of organism the amount of Candida
present in the vaginal space that
suppressive treatment may be stopped at
a period and then once again we may see
these episodic recurrences of vulva
vaginal candidiasis and so again while
not necessarily a disease of high
mortality there is significant morbidity
and discomfort and loss of productivity
that can be associated with these many
episodes of Candida in the disease or
condition that affects people fairly
significantly we see on the far right
hand side of the slide that there is an
approximate 75 percent lifetime risk
that individuals will have at least
multiple episodes of VVC throughout
their lifetime and then finally for the
tenth and final pathogen we'll be
discussing today as it relates to our
vaginitis and vaginosis is trichomonas
vaginalis again there is discharge
associated in this case the discharge is
typically green or yellow there's a foul
odor that is described and then again
vaginal and abdominal pain are described
clinically interestingly with careful
monas around 80% of infections are
asymptomatic but in symptomatic patients
what we do see
that there is some racial and ethnic
disparity associated with trichomonas
with african-american women being
affected at a higher rate around 13%
versus non-hispanic white women their
prevalence of trichomonas is also higher
in women that are over 40 years of age
and to address some of the infectious
risks infected men may be treated add to
reduce the risk of transmission to
female partners and again with
trichomonas as we saw with bacterial
vaginosis we see an increased risk of M
for HIV acquisition and increased
genital shedding of HIV infected women
now there are some overlaps between the
treatment of trichomonas vaginalis and
bacterial vaginosis with the use of
metronidazole for both of these
conditions so let's just look briefly at
some the relative abundance of
trichomonas compared to some of the
other sexually transmitted infections so
again this is a global view of sexually
transmitted infections and women in the
reproductive ages approximately and what
we can see is that trichomonas really is
a quite prevalent organism that in most
cases we see is higher than chlamydia
gonorrhea and of course syphilis but
really it is one of the most prevalent
sexually transmitted infections that is
seen in women across the globe and so
really we're talking about a global
challenge that is that we see with
trichomonas vaginalis and so Diagnostics
again is important to be able to address
these issues
and so if we take these organisms
together trichomonas bacterial vaginosis
and global vaginal candidiasis again I
think people often may consider these to
be lower risk organisms not associated
with a high mortality but because of the
higher prevalence of these organisms and
then the combined morbidity that can be
associated with some of the sequelae of
disease we find that there is a
significant economic burden and so for
trichomonas we see the economic burden
in the United States being around 19
million dollars for bacterial vaginosis
in the United States 1.3 billion dollars
just for the disease but then if you
look at these youth The Associated
Sequoyah of preterm delivery premature
rupture of membranes additional sexually
transmitted infections that could be
associated with the acquisition of
bacterial vaginosis we can get up to
four billion dollars of economic burden
in the US for bacterial vaginosis was an
overall global burden that was described
of almost 14 billion u.s. dollars and
then for vulva vaginal candidiasis
between both the over-the-counter
prescriptions and treatments along with
the loss of productivity and then
diagnostics and physicians patient
seeking care from clinicians uh we find
about a fourteen billion dollar burden
for vulva vaginal candidiasis so again
this is a pretty significant disease
state that we see here and so one of the
questions though that many people ask is
really are these laboratory tests for
vaginitis necessary can't clinicians
just make the diagnosis based on the
clinical presentation
and so in this study that compared an in
clinic test a clinician diagnosis and a
laboratory test and what we see is that
the in clinic point of care test and
just the clinic clinician diagnosis of
the clinical criteria we see
sensitivities that don't exceed 80% for
BV and then are even lower than that for
Candida and trichomonas and and so we
also see that when multiple pathogens
are detected that the clinician
diagnosis is really only about 20% less
than 30% when there's multiple pathogens
that are the cause of vaginitis and so I
think we see that we need to have
appropriate diagnostic test for
vaginitis the challenge is that there
are significant symptom overlap between
these organisms that cause bacterial
vaginosis and vaginosis BV trichomonas
and vulva vaginal candidiasis but not
only that there's other organisms that
can produce similar genital urinary
symptoms like mycoplasma genitalium
chlamydia gonorrhea urinary tract
infection HSV other organisms other
pathogens have this significant overlap
and that's why I'm good quality
Diagnostics are really important and so
as we look at the diagnostic methods
that we have available for us physician
office testing the Ansel's criteria is
the the general physicians office
clinical diagnosis that can be made
looking at the vaginal pH the
characterization of the discharge and
the release of this odor and after the
addition of potassium hydroxide to the
vaginal fluid unfortunately but to be
expected as
described in the previous slides the
sensitivities and specificities of these
criteria really are fairly low there's
also a point-of-care test that's
available for the diagnosis of bacterial
vaginosis that actually looks at the
vaginal fluid for of solid A's activity
with again fairly low sensitivities on
the lowest side the specificity for BV
is is decent but at that low sensitivity
you really run the risk of missing many
positive patients when we look at the
laboratory diagnostic methods we have
the Newton score wet prep preparations
and the culture swabs for Candida and
then these molecular diagnostic methods
that we will discuss and so as the
Nugent's core that's been mentioned a
few times we look at the presence and
score based on a Gram stain of the
vaginal secretions four grand positive
rods representative lactobacillus where
invariable rods representives
of gardnerella and in these curved
gram-negative rods representative of
mobile Uncas and based on the prevalence
of the organisms in the grand stain or
the quantity of the organism Instagram
saying each of them get a score and then
that score is interpreted as either a
normal vaginal flora that would likely
be dominated by lactobacillus an
intermediate or positive for bacterial
vaginosis and again not an excellent
sensitivity or specificity that we see
for the Nugent score with the
opportunity for both missed diagnosis at
this opposed sensitivity and specificity
and for trichomonas there are some rapid
diagnostic tests that are available
again with the sub optimal sensitivity
though the specificity performs decently
and
according to the 2015 CDC treatment
guidelines they now recommend nucleic
acid amplification test for the
sensitive and specific diagnosis of
trichomonas and many of these assays
have sensitivities and specificities
appropriate for clinical diagnosis
exceeding 95% there's also the combined
detection multiplex detection of the
organisms associated with vaginitis and
vaginosis that seen in the BB affirm
assay is a DNA probe method that detects
the presence of gardnerella vaginalis as
the marker for BV the text Candida
species as a group inclusive of the
organisms listed here and trichomonas
vaginalis and so with this assay we have
the opportunity to address some of the
issues of symptom overlap with one
sample being able to detect all of these
organisms in a single specimen and using
the DNA probe method one of the
challenges though that we do face with
the BB affirm is that there's variable
sensitivity and specificity based on the
target and in some cases due to the
target inclusivity and so what we see
with at least BV just to point out is
that there is certainly the sensitivity
is fairly good in this method but there
are some challenges with specificity
that we'll discuss in a few slides there
is some potential loss of sensitivity
with Candida so it can be difficult to
determine how much Candida is truly
associated with disease versus the
amount of Candida that's present just in
a normal vaginal tract and here the
sensitivity in this study was shown to
be
quite low although this was a relative
sensitivity and there wasn't a very
specific reference standard a gold
standard reference was not necessarily
used and so this may not be the most
accurate determination of the
sensitivity for trichomonas however the
sensitivity of this is is not as
sensitive as a nucleic acid
amplification method that's recommended
by the CDC but what this study really
did I think highlight in a very helpful
way is that using a nucleic acid
amplification test you can see what the
impact would be in these relative
prevalence of organisms so in high
incidence setting this would be in these
higher levels you see a more higher
performing assay giving you a much
better accuracy with like a 92%
diagnostic accuracy versus a 72%
diagnostic accuracy so looking for
diagnostic accuracy is really important
in these cases and so this brings me to
what was a recently fairly recently
panel developed panel by B D which is
the B D max vaginal panel that uses this
algorithmic detection of multiple
pathogens associated with bacterial
vaginosis including the identification
of lactobacillus along with other
organisms to give this algorithmic
detection of the vaginal microbiome and
then we have for the candidiasis we have
Candida group which includes Candida
albicans along with other organisms but
then separately speciate scan to the
Liberata and Candida crew CI which are
the organisms that are most associated
with resistance to routine first-line
therapy of fluconazole and then the
amplification aclinic acid amplification
detection of trichomonas
and so we performed a study where we had
a 200 compliant patients in which we had
four swabs that were collected to look
at the comparison between the B D max
panel and the previously or the current
standard of care which was the beauty of
firm assay in the patients that we had
in our study the symptoms as we see and
expected were overlapping with the most
common presentation was discharged
followed by etching and odor but there
were significant symptoms that were
present
most patients presented with two
symptoms but we had patients who had up
to six of these symptoms that excuse me
that were present in a single patient
and so there is we'll start with BV and
some of the challenges in the diagnosis
of BV so I have represented here some
graphic or visual representation of what
a Gram stain of vaginal flora might look
like and so this patient would have been
a patient who had symptoms of BV in the
upper left-hand corner the Nugent score
would be positive we've got all these
Graham variable rods a couple a single
curve rod and not too much lactobacillus
and the affirm would have called this
patient positive the patient on the
lower left-hand corner station wouldn't
have any symptoms of BB the Nugent score
would be negative probably no ansel
criteria we wouldn't have seen any clue
cells and debating affirm would have
called this patient you know negative
for BV because there was no vide card
Nerello vaginalis present but here's the
challenge what happens when you have a
patient who does have a lot of
gardnerella vaginalis but also has a
significant amount of lactobacillus is
this patient negative for BV due to the
presence of this protective left
Celes or what about the patient that has
some lactobacillus there but doesn't
necessarily have gardnerella as in high
proportion maybe there's other organisms
that could be associated with BV so a
non gardnerella vaginalis causes cause
of bacterial vaginosis so the question
that we wanted to to look at is how
these various diagnostic presentations
would fare using the current standard of
care method compared to the BD max assay
and so in our study we had 200 patients
10 we were unable to analyze and we have
this comparison between the BD max and
the BD of firm assay so what we see is
that while there were 73 tests that were
concordant between the two acids for
positive and eighty tests that were
concordant for negative there were 29
patients who are positive on the BD
affirmed but negative on the BD max and
then when we looked at the Nugent score
what we see is that there were three
patients who were positive for Nugent
but 19 patients who were negative by the
Nugent score and seven patients who were
in intermediate in the nugent score of
these patients these 29 patients who
were affirmed positive but negative by
the investigational assay the BD max
almost all of them twenty-eight up to
out of twenty nine were treated for bv
yet at least 19 of these likely did not
require BV treatment and then there were
an additional seven that were
indeterminate now when we look at the BD
max samples that were positive by
feeding max but negatives by the affirm
we see that there were three that were
positive by Nugent four that were
negative by Nugent and then one that was
in termina by Nugent so there's some
some variability in terms of the
reference method for these samples that
were positive by the
but- by the affirm and then only one of
these patients was treated for bv based
on the symptoms that were presented and
so when we look at the diagnostic
accuracy for bv when we compare the firm
to the biddy max panel what we see is
actually fairly similar sensitivity
between both of these but the
specificity of the affirm is higher at
ninety six point one percent compared to
81 percent seen in the affirm and and
what we kind of predicted is probably
the case is that on the right hand side
the patients with no symptoms for BV
perhaps these patients have a higher
presence of lactobacillus and so it's
more protective and so even on the
Nugent score they're negative but the
gardnerella vaginalis maybe what's
sizzling signaling the positive on the
affirm and then in the patients with
symptoms of BV but they're negative by
other criteria it may be these other
organisms as a B D max vaginal panel is
detecting that other than gardnerella
that are causing the symptoms of
bacterial vaginosis now when we look at
Candida we know that 70 to 75 percent of
women develop Candida vaginal
candidiasis in their lifetime and in
addition most of the time is Candida
albicans book candida glabrata is the
most common non albicans cannabis
species and the routine standard of care
may not be effective against candida
glabrata and so while the media firm as
they does detect candida glabrata it
does not differentiate it as the IBD max
vaginal panel does additionally there
are some differences the candida kefir
is present in the bt firm but absent
from the vaginal panel while candid of
deublin iNSYS is present in the vaginal
panel
but absent from the affirm so when we
looked at our study we again see that
there's there were about 42% as 42
samples that work a concordant positive
and 125 that were concordant negative
but when there was the B d-max positive
affirmed negative a significant
proportion of these had a positive
culture with six having a negative
culture what's interesting with these
samples is that if we look at the
culture growth of the samples that we
see on the BD max vaginal panel that
would have identified as Candida group
there were 52 that the panel identified
as Candida group that were Candida
albicans and then we did have one
detection of Candida deublin ences and
this one would is expected to have been
missed by the affirmed but importantly
the bt max panel are detected and
differentiated for cases of candida
glabrata detected alone and then three
additional cases of candida glabrata
detected in the presence of candida
albicans and suggested and
differentiated in the presence of
Candida albicans so we had a overall
prevalence in this study of candida
glabrata of eleven point three percent
and six of these seven patients were
treated with the standard dose of flu
comas all which may not necessarily have
been effective against candida glabrata
though the full patient follow-up has
not yet been completed for these
patients to see if they continue to
present with additional symptoms so what
we see in this study is that we have
improved sensitivity for detection of
Candida and that's been confirmed by the
reference culture there is a slight
decrease but not
and in the specificity do to fix what's
been determined it's false positive
Candida results but this may be due to
the increased detection of Candida as
part of as a amplification molecular
amplification test results and in this
study we did look at a trichomonas we
had a very low prevalence in this study
with only 8 positive patients and the
results were concordance between the
vaginal panel and the affirm and so when
we look at the patient's prevalence by
age we see in this study the blue line
is the age of the patients and we have a
higher proportion of younger patients in
this study and the prevalence of BV by
the red line we see occurs in patients
from 18 to 50 years old while Candida we
see over the entire span of the patients
here interestingly in our study that we
normally expect to see trichomonas in
patients over 40 in this study likely
due to the lower number of patients in
the study we only saw trichomonas in the
younger patient population and finally I
just wanted to take a quick look at the
detection of multiple pathogens
so if we see look at BV BV was seen in
combination with all of the other
targets that we're seeing 49 x patients
only had BV but was also detected in
other instances with Candida candida
glabrata and actually seven of the eight
trichomonas positive specimens were also
positive for bacterial vaginosis at
candidate group was usually detected by
itself or with candida glabrata and then
candida glabrata was then you know
usually it could be detected with
Candida
group or BV or it could just be C seen
alone and then again there was just one
patient that was positive for
trichomonas in the absence of any other
positives so finally we can see with the
overall performance of the B team X
vaginal panel if we look at the
diagnostic accuracy of the affirm over
these 200 patients the affirmed in our
population had a diagnostic accuracy of
seventy nine point two percent while the
PDMS molecular panel had a diagnostic
accuracy of 93 percent with a hundred
and eighty six out of 200 patients being
appropriately diagnosed based on our
reference of comparison methods in this
study so in summary we know that
vaginitis is a worldwide challenge with
significant economic impact for
diagnosis treatment and then the
associated adverse outcomes as described
earlier we know that the vaginal
microbiome is complex and we need to do
a better job of understanding dysbiosis
and using our understanding of vaginal
display osis for the data development
and utilization of diagnostic methods
here i present a study in which we
examine the use of the BD max vaginal
panel and we shall improve specificity
for the detection of bacterial vaginosis
improve sensitivity for the detection
and differentiation of a candida
glabrata of note we didn't have any
candidate crew CID tested in the study
population and overall we saw an
improvement in the diagnostic accuracy
when using the Betamax vaginal panel for
the detection of vaginitis and so with
that I would like to conclude the
presentation today and thank the
individuals that participated in this
study and the recruitment of patients
for this study thank you very much
and I think we can open up for questions
thank you dr. Colbert for your
informative presentation and yes it's
time to start our like Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask the optical breaths please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for those
questions that we are unable to answer
today live and those submitted during
the on-demand period will be entered via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration so let's get
started
start your clock with our first question
what is your perspective on how women
are being diagnosed with Nugent scoring
is this a common practice I think it is
a fairly common practice among
laboratories our laboratory actually
continues to offer Nugent's score and so
I think laboratories are offering Nugent
score it is being utilized but as
described there are three challenges
with the sensitivity and specificity of
the Nugent score for the diagnosis of
bacterial vaginosis which really brings
us to the need of improved diagnostic
methods
now what organisms that are not visible
in a Nugent's core Gram stain are
important to consider for assessing VV
yeah so there's some other organisms
that are just actually I think really
important and it's on one of the earlier
slides it's a lot of organisms that are
associated with bacterial vaginosis and
higher Nugent scores many of those
organisms are either non potable or not
visible readily visible on the Gram
stain so this includes organisms like
mega Fira organisms like bacterial
vaginosis associated bacteria one and
two and multiple other organisms that
are either not visible or not counted in
the Nugent's core criteria and so this
is where the utilization of molecular
methods can really enhance our ability
to detect and diagnose bacterial
vaginosis when the scoring criteria is
either unavailable for these organisms
that are more difficult to see in the
Nugent's core or adding in then all of
these different morphologies would just
make a Gram stain scoring method so
complicated that i think it becomes no
longer viable for laboratories to
perform even now the nujin score though
you know fairly prevalent is still a
pretty complicated challenge for
laboratories to be able to execute in a
timely manner with the volume of tests
that many facilities see
thank you dr. Cole breath now next
question does the BD max test report
give the result of each target by name
or does it use an algorithm to report as
positive or negative for BB it's an
algorithm and so it is reported as the
flora is either consistent or
inconsistent with bacterial vaginosis
but it does not name the specific
targets that are positive and the
bacterial vaginosis called it does for
Candida and it will speed differentiate
Candida group vs. candida glabrata
versus Candida crew CI but it does not
go through each of those organisms for
bacterial vaginosis
what is the liability of using a
non-fda-approved assay and there are
guidelines by that are given by
regulatory bodies for how laboratory
should validate and implement non
fda-cleared assays I would point out
that both the bt max vaginal panel and
the biddy affirm are both FDA cleared
assays but if a laboratory was using a
non FDA cleared sa there are guidelines
for how laboratories could implement
those methods
thank you dr. Cobras our next question
for BV particularly how important is it
to know the presence or absence of
specific BV related organism and with
knowing these the clinical clinically
relevant and in turn would it impact
therapy decisions yeah so that's an
interesting question
um you know I think to know the species
of organisms is probably not as relevant
because many of the therapies have not
necessarily been organism specific it's
been more condition related but what I
do think is important to point out is
that knowing or having a method that
takes into account the entire community
of organisms that are present which is
basically what the Nugent score does it
takes into account the entire community
I think having a molecular method that
takes into account the entire community
to then give a result is important
because different from many of the other
diagnostic or the disease states that we
examine bacterial vaginosis is not just
the presence or absence of a single
pathogen our target
it is a dysbiosis or a change in the
global community
so I think single organism
identification is really not as
important as an understanding of what's
happening in the community of the the
vaginal space
our next question relative to the
comparative study you performed in your
lab can you speak a little to this
species speciation of glabrata and crew
say and how this capability with the
beauty max vaginal panel resonated with
the physician providers yeah I think
that's a great question thank you I
think first there were a lot of
questions with providers really and
maybe and I think the question would be
for many of the providers would be how
what are they supposed to do with
candida glabrata for many providers
regardless of the method that was used
in the past maybe with the exception of
culture they would not have ever known
that the candida species was candida
glabrata and so through this study this
didn't we did not the study was not
perspective it was retrospective and so
the results were not provided back to
the clinical providers but I think it
begins to give opportunity one to
recognize the prevalence of candida
glabrata and then two to really
understand better if different
treatments are required for vulva
vaginal candidiasis associated with
candida glabrata perhaps it may not
necessarily change initial therapy that
would be given in the providers office
before the result is generated by the
laboratory but perhaps it would impact
follow a therapy after recurrence and
perhaps some of these recurrent
infections are due to sub optimal
therapy of a fluconazole resistant
organism like candida glabrata or
candida crew CI when its treated with
the routine standard of care buchanan's
all over multiple episodes so I think
long term we may be able to see an
impact of being able to speciate candida
glabrata through through other studies
looking at the prospective use of assays
do that type of differentiation thank
you dr. Koh breath and we have time for
just a few more questions aerobics a
tinnitus is a recently recognized badge
and itis did you think or look into some
of your patients that did not fit the
diagnosis of BBB BC or trick thank you
for that question
aerobic vegetative this definitely is an
emerging entity definitely poses some
challenges in Diagnostics as many of the
organisms that are usually associated
with aerobic vaginitis can be part of
the normal vaginal or GU flora and so we
did not specifically look at aerobics
vaginitis as a potential cause of
bacterial vaginosis or vaginal
discomfort in this study and I think it
still remains an area that requires
additional investigation into the
appropriate diagnostic methods for
aerobic vaginitis
thank you next one are we over treating
bv and can beezie clear itself without
Metro die easily what are your thoughts
on using boric acid suppositories okay
you said this is quite a clinical
question but I would say that based on
our study and others one challenge is to
the diagnosis of BV because we have
lacked sensitive and specific methods
when you lack specificity that results
in more false positive results being
detected and so we saw that potentially
with the standard of care reference that
was used in our study compared to the bt
max so the standard of care lacked
specificity and so it was calling more
positives than were truly seen
clinically and we saw that with other
assays and so I think by having a more
specific diagnostic test you reduce a
number of false positives there by
having more more specific results and I
think that might then address some of
the the issues of over treatment
okay no I almost out of time let's just
see if we can I know there are several
questions in here that we haven't gone
through and I know more will be coming
in let's go ahead and save these
questions to answer via email and dr.
Culver do you have any final comments
for our audience No thank you for your
time and attention and there were great
great questions so thank you very much
thank you again and we want to thank our
audience for their great questions today
and we also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor PD for sponsoring today's
webinar now I just want to remind our
audience for those that questions that
we did not answer they will be answered
via email following the presentation
this webinar can be viewed on demand and
leverage will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event a quick survey will now pop
up on your screen and we appreciate your
participation as it does help improve
our webinar program thanks for joining
us today and we hope to see you again
soon